o fue abandonado y se deteriora hasta quedar en ruinas.
JCPenney ya no está de rebajas.
(Risas)
Comencé a producir esta serie a principios de 2015
después de pasar por una fase oscura en mi vida
donde simplemente ya no me apetecía hacer más películas.
Guardé mi cámara
y simplemente paré de hacer cine.
En 2015, decidí hacer un cortometraje sobre el centro comercial Owings Mills.
Owings Mills Mall abrió sus puertas en 1986.
Lo sé porque estuve allí el día de la inauguración.
Estaba allí con mi familia,
como cualquier otra familia en Baltimore,
y aquel día tenías que dar vueltas durante 45 minutos
solo para encontrar un lugar para estacionar.
Como se pueden imaginar,
esto ya no sucede hoy en los centros comerciales.
Mi primer trabajo en un centro comercial cuándo era adolescente
fue en una tienda de artículos deportivos llamada Herman's World of Sports.
Quizás se acuerden de ella.
(Cantando) Herman's World of Sports.
¿La recuerdan?
(Risas)
Sí, así que trabajé en una tienda de calzado femenino,
trabajé en una tienda de artículos de cuero,
y también trabajé en una tienda de videos,
y como no era muy aficionado de las artes de la venta minorista...
(Risas)
me despidieron de cada trabajo.
Entre dos de este tipo de puestos de trabajo mal pagados
hice lo que cualquier adolescente normal hacia en los 90.
Robaba en las tiendas.
Estoy bromeando.
Quedaba con mis amigos en el centro comercial.
(Risas)
Todo el mundo se está preguntado: "Oh Dios mío, pero, ¿qué charla es esta?"
Pasarte el día en el centro comercial
podía ser divertido, pero también lamentable,
parecido a compartir un cigarrillo con un desempleado en sus 40
qué se ha puesto lápiz labial negro la noche anterior
durante tu pausa de comer de tu trabajo de mierda de salario mínimo.
Mientras estoy aquí hablando,
Owings Mills ha sido vaciado
y está listo para ser demolido.
La última vez que estuve allí, fue por la noche,
unos tres días antes de que lo cerraran para siempre.
Y me quede con la sensación,
aunque nunca anunciaron su cierre,
pero me quedé con la sensación, esa sensación agobiante
de que algo grande iba a suceder,
como si fuera el final del camino.
Fue un paseo muy siniestro por el centro comercial.
Permítanme mostrarles.
(Música)
Cuando empecé a producir la serie de centros comerciales muertos
subí los videos a YouTube,
y aunque creía que eran interesantes,
francamente no pensé que otros compartirían el entusiasmo
para un tema tan deprimente y sombrío.
Pero aparentemente estaba equivocado,
porque mucha gente empezó a dejar comentarios.
Y al principio los comentarios eran básicamente algo así:
"Oh, Dios mío, es el centro comercial de mi infancia. ¿Qué pasó?"
Y luego me llegaban comentarios de gente que decía:
"Hay un centro comercial abandonado en mi ciudad. Deberías venir a filmarlo."
Así que empecé a viajar por la zona del Atlántico medio
para filmar estos centros comerciales muertos.
Algunos estaban abiertos.
Algunos fueron abandonados.
Siempre era un poco difícil entrar en los que fueron abandonados,
pero de alguna manera siempre encontré una manera de entrar.
(Risas)
Los que todavía están abiertos,
siempre hacen esta cosa extraña de los centros comerciales muertos.
Les quedan tres tiendas
pero tratan de cosmetizarlo
para dar la impresión que las cosas están mejorando.
Por ejemplo, hay una tienda vacía
y cierran la puerta.
En Owings Mills, por ejemplo, ponen esta lona sobre la puerta.
Y tiene una foto de archivo
de una mujer que está tan feliz
y que está sosteniendo una blusa,
y tiene esta actitud...
(Risas)
Y luego hay un chico junto a ella,
con una taza de Espresso, así
(Risas)
y dice: "¿Qué te trae por aquí hoy?"
Tenía ganas de asustarme y deprimirme.
Gracias.
Bueno, los comentarios seguían llegando
en los videos,
de todo el país y luego de todo el mundo.
Y empecé a pensar, esto podría llegar a algo bueno,
pero tengo que ser creativo, porque en fin,
¿cuánto tiempo aguantará la gente sentada
para verme deambulando por un centro comercial vacío?
(Risas)
Filmé los episodios originales con un iPhone.
Así que caminaba por el centro comercial con un iPhone, y, ya saben.
Así.
(Risas)
Y los de seguridad - porque en los centros comerciales, no les gusta la fotografía -
me abordaban diciendo: "Para esto", y yo claro, contestaba: "Bien".
Así que tuve que ser creativo y disimular
así que empecé a usar una cámara oculta y diferentes técnicas
para obtener las imágenes que necesitaba,
y básicamente lo que quería hacer
era hacer el video
como si fuera una experiencia en primera persona,
como si estuvieras sentado -
ponerte los auriculares para mirar la pantalla -
y tener la sensación de estar allí en el video,
como en un videojuego, básicamente.
También comencé a añadir música,
colaborando con artistas que crean música llamada vaporwave.
Y vaporwave es un género musical
que surgió a principios de 2010 entre las comunidades de internautas.
Aquí hay un ejemplo.
(Música)
Esta pieza es de un artista llamado Desconsciente
de un álbum que hizo llamado "Hologram Plaza".
Así que si lo buscan, pueden escuchar más de sus melodías.
Vaporwave es más que una forma de arte. Es como un movimiento.
Es nihilista, es depresivo,
pero es de alguna manera reconfortante.
Toda la estética es una manera de enfrentarse a cosas
cosas sobre las cuales no puedes hacer nada,
como por ejemplo no tener trabajo,
o tener que vivir en el sótano de tus padres comiendo fideos.
Vaporwave salió del deseo de esta generación de expresar su desesperación,
de la misma manera que lo hizo la generación pre-Internet
sentados en la zona de autoservicio.
Uno de mis centros comerciales favoritos
se encontraba
en Corpus Christi, y se llama Sunrise Mall.
Cuando yo era un niño,
me encantaba ir a ver películas,
y solía ver estas películas una y otra y otra vez.
Y una de mis películas favoritas era "La Leyenda de Billie Jean".
Para aquellos de Uds. que han visto "La leyenda de Billie Jean,"
sabrán que es una gran película.
Me encanta.
Y Helen Slater y Christian Slater -
y si no lo sabían, no son familia.
Muchas gente cree que son hermanos, pero no lo son.
De todos modos, Sunrise Mall aparece en la película por ser el lugar de rodaje.
Hoy, el centro comercial es exactamente el mismo que en 1984.
Estamos hablando de 32 años más tarde. Déjenme enseñarleslo.
(Video) Dan Bell: Y aquí está Billie Jean corriendo por la fuente,
perseguida por los amigos de Hubie Pyatt.
Aquí es donde salta.
Y pueden ver en esta escena aquí mismo que es lo mismo que pueden ver hoy.
Es bastante increíble.
Quiero decir, honestamente, se ve exactamente igual.
Y allí es donde están cayendo en la fuente,
y ella sube por las escaleras.
Este es un buen marco de donde se puede ver todo.
Dan Bell: Me encanta eso.
(Risas)
Siempre pienso en mi cabeza, si tuviera un centro comercial muerto -
¿por qué no aprovechan este aspecto vintage?
Ponerle un bar,
ofrecer comida vegetariana en la zona para comer
e invitar a los "millenials", a los hipsters también
venir para beber y comer,
y les garantizo que dentro de tres semanas
H&M y Levi's estarán haciendo fila en la puerta para alquilar espacio.
No sé por qué no lo hacen,
pero aparentemente,
solo se me ocurre a mí y todo el tiempo.
(Risas)
De todos modos, para cerrar...
Cuando me pidieron que diera esta charla,
dije,
"¿Creen que soy la persona adecuada?"
(Risas)
Estas charlas se supone que serán inspiradoras y tal...
Sin embargo, recordé algo.
Guardé mi cámara hace tres o cuatro años,
e hizo falta ir a estos centros comerciales
para que vuelva a sentirme inspirado.
Y ver a mi audiencia
y a personas de todo el mundo escribiéndome y diciéndome:
"Dios, me encantan tus videos,"
es algo increíble.
No sé ni siquiera cómo explicarlo,
porque como artista,
esto es muy gratificante.
Si me hubieran dicho hace un año
que iba a estar en este escenario
hablándoles a todas estas personas maravillosas,
nunca lo hubiera creído.
Me siento honrado
y muy agradecido.
Muchas gracias.
(Aplausos)